i couldn't believe this because this
will get people's attention if you want
to mark how things have changed the
final episode of cheers watched by 84.4
million people
oh my god now i heard anecdotally the
other day someone was talking about a
network
show one of those kind of reality
game show type shows i don't remember
which one that it got
picked up for another season
and it got a 0.5 in the demo and got
picked up
that's the world we're in yes it is that
uh if you can get nine people watching a
television
you are you know everyone wants to hand
you a cigar and pop the champagne uh
it's it and it must seem otherworldly to
you
it's it's i think was it david zaslav
who's running uh discovery now so
there's 580
shows on the air now yeah you know and
there's what i don't know how many
networks 100
maybe 150 i always say when i started
out there were three networks and 30
great comedy writers
now there are
150 networks and 30 great companies yeah
you know yeah
but that's
that goes to
this image i've had for a long time is
what changed is the technology this
delivery system
changed so that
suddenly instead of there being
three networks not suddenly but very
quickly and especially with streaming
there was the capability
uh because of the delivery system in the
economics that's what changed and
suddenly there could be 600
shows but why would you suddenly expect
humankind
to suddenly get
500 times more talented it it's it's not
and i always think of it as
people wondering i don't understand
technology just enabled us to widen the
bathtub
by 50 feet
what happened to the water level and
you're like this is uh
this is what it is now i'm i think
there's so much there's a lot of really
brilliant
stuff out there but it's still hard to
find because the volume
is insane the volume of just noise and
you know
there's just i never i i'm always cast
adrift if i don't know specifically what
show i'm looking for you can't scroll i
used to just scroll through television
back in the day
and you could find something that caught
you
there's no way you would scroll now it's
like saying i'm just going to wander the
mojave desert and see what happens
my wife and i have done that and we've
wasted the entire evening scrolling and
never watched anything and it just
became like walking through the video
store or something
yeah it's it's
because the shows that are hits
you know like ozark and you know it has
five million bytes on
on on
on netflix or
it's just those are rare and probably
if you call it all down it's probably
the same as when there were three
networks
yeah you know all the good shows because
that's where all the shows went all the
good shows went on those three networks
so it's just now so diverse that you can
find a specific show for your your your
your
your idiosyncrasy and watch it and maybe
four other people are watching it
i uh
when i first got started back in 1985
there was always this kind of sense out
there that
the place
people really wanted to get to was
movies you could
because that somehow more prestigious
and
that would be something that you'd hear
sometimes have you ever thought of
writing a movie or get into the movies
and i always thought there's nothing
better for a writer than television
in you know as as you know
you can
you can do such good work in television
and because the way it's structured
writers have a lot more power in
television than they do in movies in
movies that are completely rewritten
they're at the very bottom
of the totem pole
in uh
in movies
and have always been treated with a kind
of disdain and let's just get another
writer in here and let's you know let's
completely redo it
but
writers are at the center of television
and uh
so much of i mean what i've one thing i
really love about your book is you just
reprint
pages of great dialogue from all these
shows
and i'm reading them
and it's like you say it's just great
radio writing the rhythm is all there
it's terrific
solid writing that
uh is as good today as it was when it
was first done and it's uh
it's all you know um
was brilliantly realized whereas if it
were a movie i think chances are a lot
of that could have been
rewritten tossed out cut out
those those uh
the dialogue in the book is from is from
the shows
from some of the shows i've done but
those
that's tried and true because
those sequences got huge laughs
and when we're doing a show
if you write a joke and it doesn't get a
laugh you go back and rewrite the joke
and if it doesn't get a laugh you go
back and rewrite the joke
you don't rely on the writers you rely
on 200 300 people behind you
in movies you're relying on the director
and the writer and it may not
you know may not appeal to an audience
but those
that dialogue in there got huge huge
laughs
especially willing grace which is just
one
probably the funniest show i ever did
really you think will and grace i've
loved that show but thinking of all of
them you think that was was it the
writing or the writing plus the cast
it's the cast it's outrageous it's the
first really other than third rock from
the sun which i did the pilot of
it's the most outrageous show i ever did
i like to say it's a fairy tale
figuratively and literally
oh it's a show with four girls yeah and
uh it's just the jokes are so
hard
and so strong especially karen's jokes
and jack's jokes and uh you know it's
just it's you know cheers my favorite
will always be my favorite because uh
it's i'm part of birthing that show
but um
will and grace
laughs per page
is is the funniest show because cheers
was
we were about four minutes longer
than will and grace we were about 26
minutes will and grace was 21 and a half
minutes
so you could go a couple of pages
without a joke on cheers which we did a
lot of sam and diane scenes are very
riveting
and you know tension filled but there's
always
you know after a page or a page or two
pages this joke that undercuts it all
and makes it
you know
it relieves you from the anger from the
uh from the the dramatic moment
but on on will grace he couldn't do that
he didn't have enough time so it's
just joke after joke and uh
just the funniest show per you know per
per well the compression the comedy
compression yeah is uh
is there and that show had such a
fascinating arc because it it it ran
uh had a great run big hit beloved
it it it leaves
and then it comes back
a number of years later and i was trying
i was hard-pressed to think of another
show that that did that the connors
yeah the connor that's right that's
right they and their
their show is just as good even without
roseanne it's amazing
because they have that it's one of my
favorite shows because they have that
style
this they underplay everything
everything is like this you know goodman
is like this and lori's like this you
know every there's not effort but
there's this rhythm in that show you
know they don't hit you over the head
with the jokes it's just
wow